alright folks welcome back
so now we'll learn about the process of
learning to fly and some of the
regulations around it that will be on
the test
alright so when you learn to fly you'll
preflight the aircraft for the
instructor and learn about that how to
inspect everything the first few lessons
are really about learning to see the
aircraft attitude seeing whether you're
pitched up pitch down bank left or right
most people have a fairly easy time with
then you'll learn to take off and land
as I said earlier that takes about five
or ten hours and in fact people used to
solo after four hours of flight training
especially young people now it takes a
little long because they wanted you to
know about more bureaucracy and how to
talk to the control tower and so forth a
good trainer airplane why not start with
the best and just learn how to fly your
personal Gulfstream or whatever if it's
a very heavy airplane like a Gulfstream
which can weigh a hundred thousand
pounds then you have to think ahead
because of inertia the airplane tends to
keep doing whatever it was doing five or
ten seconds earlier at the same time
though a really tiny airplane like some
of the little two-seaters they are
unstable and they just get kicked around
by the wind so much that you're not sure
if it's something you did or something
that the environment did to you also
people have gotten heavier the owner of
East Coast Aero Club says that when he
started in the 80s 85% of the customers
and instructors could train in the
two-seat piper tomahawk now 85% require
training in the four-seat piper warrior
you don't want it to be too powerful
actually and that's because when you go
from on a go-around for example and you
go from near idle power to full power
that's a huge transition and those
left-turning tendencies that tina
mentions mean that you need immediate
and significant rudder input and so
forth so an airplane that has an hour or
band of possible powers is easier to
learn on
you want something that won't spin if
it's abused and also ideally and
airplane that if you just let go the
Cessnas tend to have this characteristic
they'll come out of most bad situations
if you just let go of the yoke so
they're best trainers my personal
favorite is the diamond da40 it's kind
of physically uncomfortable which is why
I don't use it as a family airplane
anymore
the Cessna 172 and piper warrior are the
most popular you can check these out
the cirrus sr20 is the most popular
personal or the 20 and the 22 together
the most popular family and personal
airplane these days there are ok
trainers and some airline training
programs and college training programs
use them but they're a little bit more
challenging to handle than assessment as
diamonds and Piper's the marginal
operating cost of all of these is about
100 to 150 dollars an hour so if flight
schools usually have to mark that up a
bit in order to stay in business because
they have to cover the fixed cost as
well of owning the aircraft hangar ring
and paying insurance but and that that
cost includes you know the fuel and the
engine overhaul in the prop overhaul
what about doing gliders so we don't
want to sell you too hard on the idea of
just starting in a single-engine land
airplane you can go out to Sterling
Massachusetts get towed up to 3,000 feet
and then on a handful of good summer
days stay up by soaring in the thermals
ridge lifts people have soared all the
way down for I think about a thousand
miles tend to be the record for soaring
that's usually on following the edge of
a mountain range where the wind blowing
let's say from the west generates a lift
right at the on the western edge of the
mountain range or right in the center
you can be a captain so a style hero
on every landing actually
raise your hand if you think that there
is another pilot in the aircraft with
captain Sully or if he was by himself
who thinks there was a second pilot in
there okay who knows the name of the
second pilot without going to your phone
does anybody in this room know the name
of that second pilot alright Jeff Skiles
alright hold on a sec we got to give
this guy his reward
I'll pay out twenty dollars a student
for that answer
I only probably a handful of cash
because I knew I wouldn't need most of
it okay a good trainer helicopter same
issues the really light helicopters
Robinson r22 is very popular for
training because it's inexpensive to
operate but it's so light that it's
unstable and gives people the impression
that heroic skills are required also you
want reasonable amount of rotor inertia
for auto rotations and helicopters a lot
of the training after those ten hours
after you've learned to fly you also
need to learn to fly a helicopter with
no engine and that requires making some
adjustments in the pitch of the rotating
blades or rotating spinning wings so if
there's no inertia in those blades then
it becomes a little bit harder to
control during the auto rotation if
you're a student you may not make the
best landings so rugged skids this ends
up all pointing towards the Robinson r44
it's a four-seat helicopter and those
extra two empty seats in the back give
you a lot of performance margin that's
more expensive to operate and therefore
the prices that flight schools have to
charge are higher because all the
rotating components get thrown out every
2200 hours the blades the transmissions
there's more that gets overhauled okay
you can get a pilot certificate from the
FAA
by doing your pre solo written exam with
an instructor on the characteristics of
the aircraft and anything that's
important locally then you do some solo
flight after your training you'll do
some flights by yourself you will do
cross-country trips so you will go with
an instructor on some trips that are at
least 50 nautical miles if you're in an
airplane 25 in a helicopter that's
called cross country you don't have to
go all the way to California or Alaska
and then you'll do a bit of solo
cross-country flying you will do a check
ride preparation that has to be able to
leave at least three hours in prep with
an instructor for your check ride and
lets you take your check ride with an
FAA employee or designated pilot
examiner you get issued the pilot
certificate it takes you about 40 hours
of flight time and I believe only 10 of
that has to be solo the other 30 is
typically with an instructor 55 hours
it's probably more typical but young
people like yourselves who do it
intensively can come and finish in
pretty close to the 40 hours there's my
certificate notice it says airline
transport pilot there let's use the
fancier feature airline transport pilot
so that's a different level of
certificate there's a private commercial
and ATP again beyond the scope notice
also there's a hole punched in it
because when you get an additional
rating they issue a new certificate and
destroy the old one oops okay what can
you do once you have your private you
can go anywhere in the world in a US
registered airplane and carry friends
and family as long as you're not
charging the money you can fly at night
that's not true in some other countries
but it is true in the US you don't need
any additional rating to fly on that you
will have had three hours of training
and night flying with an instructor and
you will fly what you learned in so if
your mom has a hot air balloon and that
was your first aircraft you will have a
rating for
flying that hot-air balloon it doesn't
have to you don't have to start with a
Cessna or similar okay so Congress
passes kind of loose laws about aviation
but really most of the things that you
might think of as laws governing flying
are actually regulations that are
drafted by the bureaucrats in the FAA
and the agency a lot of these stuff is
public you can look up anybody who
claims to be a pilot and the airman
registry one reason it's not called the
pilot registry is that there are
actually other functions for which
certificates are issued for example
flight engineer maybe in the old days
there was navigator
similarly airplanes if you see an
interesting airplane you can look up the
tail number and see to whom it's
registered sometimes it's obscured with
you know a shell LLC somewhere but again
it can be interesting okay this is one
of the worst parts of at the FAA and the
exam they use the words category in
classes in two different ways one is for
getting your pilot certificate in which
case a category is something like
airplane or rotor craft and then you
have this class which could be you know
multi-engine see in the case of this
Grumman I think it might be a mallard
there on the right then 1940s Grumman
seaplane so that's a multi-engine c
rating that you would have in the
airplane category here's your little
matrix you can study this from the books
but you see these are different
categories of aircraft here on the left
some of the fun ones like powered
parachute weight shift control
fortunately there are no flight schools
for those kind of aircraft that I know
of in the area wouldn't be much fun in a
New England February category class very
exciting okay so just to give you an
overview of the pilot and instructor
certification on the left here you have
your levels of pilot
concentrating on private pilot
recreational pilot is extremely
unpopular sport pilot is just a handful
of schools for that as well so really
it's private commercial ATP are the
three core levels of a pilot certificate
to those you add ratings so airplane
single-engine land that lets you fly the
icon a5 seaplane that you might have
seen and you also need type ratings for
heavier or turbojet powered aircraft
that means you've had special training
for your dc-3 which is heavy or for your
Boeing 737 which has turbo jets okay the
flight instructor has a separate
certificate and that has its own set of
ratings which are simpler so
single-engine airplane notice it doesn't
say Landers C so I have a commercial
seaplane rating and I have an instructor
certificate for single-engine airplane
so for anybody who wants to die by
drowning I can offer you instruction in
a single-engine seaplane or a
multi-engine seaplane for that matter
oh there are too many of those there is
a totally separate certificate if you
are also passionate about drones you'll
end up with three pieces of plastic one
for the pilot certification one for the
instructor and one for being a remote
pilot okay so aircraft they use the same
words but to mean different things we
will have a normal or utility category
of aircraft or acrobatic those are the
three that you're going to see at your a
typical flight school on the right there
is the game bird a very interesting
plane that I just flew in Bentonville
Arkansas I would encourage you guys to
look that up and then you have class so
you can have you know if you have a
really big helicopter it's a transport
category and rotorcraft class all right
there on the right is I think that's a
Pitcairn autogyro so that's at
rotorcraft autogyro from
the 1930s that's a replica at from
Oshkosh which we'll hear about at
lunchtime
okay the bureaucracies you have the NTSB
the National Transportation Safety Board
a little bit separate from the FAA which
is part of the Department of
Transportation the structure of
regulations the Code of Federal
Regulations is huge I think it's doubled
in size in the last twenty years or so
the FAA is part of that in title 14 if
you look up the FAR's the Federal
Aviation Regulations oftentimes will be
directed to a site that has the entire
electronic Code of Federal Regulations
the most relevant parts for this class
are 61 what does it mean to become a
pilot and part 91 what can you do if
you're flying privately if you want to
have fun extra knowledge these are some
of the other FAR's that are occasionally
worth looking at you can look at doing
charter and airline operations those
have air carrier certificates and then
you add something for scheduled big
airplanes like 401 21 or smaller charter
airplanes 135 if you want to see what
kind of engineering you have to
demonstrate to the FAA to get your
product certified you can look into for
example far 27 to see what Robinson had
to do for the r44 to show that it was
safe okay far 61 is about pilots flight
instructors at ground instructors the
standards are actually sort of
reasonable like you have to do a flight
review with an instructor every two
years in order to continue to exercise
the privileges of your certificate if
you want to add for example the
capability to fly in the clouds that's
the instrument rating that Tina was
talking about and that's in far 61.65
some of these are just sign-off like for
high-performance or complex you just
need an endorsement from an instructor
that you did it for the type ratings
you'll actually get a new pilot
certificate after you know usually
simulator training at a simulator Center
all right so these are some of the
things that you need to know for the
test you have two until until nine
eleven the pilot certificate was a piece
of paper I think and the photo ID was
not required so you could just go out
and fly with your piece of paper and
your medical certificate now you don't
need that actually because of this thing
called basic med you have to you know I
guess that you have to know I think for
some test question that they can be
inspected by these various agencies all
right
drugs and alcohol this is actually one
of the worst parts of the FAA
certification projects for young people
people my age we don't get invited to
parties so getting arrested for DUI it's
not really an issue but I know this guy
really wonderful young guy about 20 very
enthusiastic very smart he was in
college you know he was drinking and you
know he got arrested for DUI and the FAA
treated him you know like they would you
know if I were arrested for DUI it would
mean that I was an alcoholic but you
know he was not an alcoholic
but they don't have different standards
so they can't just say well he's in
college so of course he's drinking they
said well he's an alcoholic so they
wanted to do years of proving that he
went to you know alcohol treatment
programs and all this other stuff so
really you have to be you have to report
any time that you have an
alcohol-related infraction with a motor
vehicle and that's how I would say this
is probably the number one reason that
pilots lose their certificates marijuana
I was just in Haiti actually and the
shaman was showing about the tourist
part of Haiti of course but the you know
the authentic Haiti so the shaman was
showing us the 50 different medicinal
plants that they used to treat various
ailments and I said you know you guys
are so primitive and in Massachusetts we
have one plant that people say well cure
almost any kind of problem
it's medical marijuana so you can't
really it's you can't really be a STONER
and honestly answer the questions on the
despite the legality in Massachusetts
you can't be a STONER and hold your
pilot's certificate because you're
supposed to tell the FAA about you know
your glaucoma and you know how you're
treating it with medical marijuana so
the certificate duration is two years
for flight instructors they want us to
to do recurrent training or sign-off so
many students that we don't need it
for remote pilot they want you to pass
the test every two years the pilot
certificate never expires here's a
couple pictures from last week I was out
in Sonoma California and I stumbled on
this Airport where one pilot was flying
this 1940s Howard airplane that you see
on the left and another pilot was flying
this p-51 Mustang which on a 2500 foot
runway that's a pretty short runway for
and it's very windy nasty wind patterns
off the bay so that's kind of a short
runway for a three million dollar
airplane
those were $1,500 by the way when the
government sold them as surplus at the
end of World War two but anyway those
pilot certificates never expired
somebody could not fly for 30 years go
out and do a little bit of recurrent
training and get signed off by an
instructor for a flight review and fly
again
assuming I guess they he or she would
need to get a renewed medical
certificate for you all you're gonna
have a third class medical that will be
valid for five years everything's based
on calendar month so if you get it on
the first of June it'll expire at the
end of June five years later airline
pilots need first-class medicals the
captain needs a first-class medical by
regulation might be true of the first
officer to in just ordinary charter use
or doing helicopter sightseeing or
whatever that's the second class medical
operation one reason that people like
sport pilot and glider flying is that
these medicals are not required
if they think that they might not pass a
medical and I'll transition to one of
those I think they say that you have to
have a current driver's license and you
know kind of it's a little bit of self
reporting you have to basically consider
yourself to be healthy basic med you
start with the third class during your
training and then you'll go every four
years to a regular doctor you can see in
far 61 1 1 3 that there's a limit to
what you can do under basic med you
can't fly a a heavy fast airplane with a
lot of people in it ok for most tests
you need an endorsement from an
instructor for the check ride it can be
you can pass it it can be discontinued
maybe the weather turned bad you can
fail usually on one or two maneuvers you
can retake the failed test which might
only be on those one or two maneuvers at
the examiners discretion you have to log
sufficient to prove to the FAA that you
meet currency requirements like you've
done three takeoffs and landings within
the last 90 days if you're carrying
passengers or that you had a flight
review within two years
that's from I have a nephew in medical
school so you're supposed to grab
yourself if you get sick so you got a
medical certificate five years ago but
you know if you're not fit to fly and
you can have yourself as a regulation
about that the flight review requires an
hour of ground and an hour of flight at
a minimum or whatever the instructor
thinks that you need to be safe or if
you get a new pilot certificate for
example because you got an instrument
rating then the flight review is not
required so oftentimes people are
enthusiastic about it they won't have a
flight review for the first five or ten
years of their aviation journey because
they keep getting new certificates for
this or that the insurance requirements
for more complex aircraft usually
require training every 12 months so they
essentially are more stringent than the
FAA requirements okay so as I mentioned
you need to have done some recent flying
by yourself or with passengers before
you can take additional passengers and
if you're gonna carry passengers at
night which is defined for this currency
as one hour after sunset - one hour
before sunrise you have to have done
three takeoffs and landings to a full
stop before you can carry passengers at
night this system one where people often
have trouble maintaining their currency
and have to make a special trip to the
airport to build currency this has to be
in Category class and type if applicable
so if it's a jet you have to if you're
typed in a Boeing 737 you have to have
done the three takeoffs and landings at
night in your Boeing 737 to be current
to take more passengers at night it's
not enough to do it just in a Cessna 172
the flight review oddly enough doesn't
work that way you can do it in any of
the aircraft for which you're rated
again the insurance company might be
stricter about that okay tell the FAA if
you move this is packing up for a recent
trip to Florida so it sure looked like
we were moving let me tell you once you
have a light aircraft and a family every
trip becomes just like that movie
Sophie's Choice
you have to decide who or what is going
to be left behind it's pretty painful
okay student pilot before you console
you pass a little written test that's
kind of chosen and given by the CFI you
have to receive training on specific
listed maneuvers that are in this far 61
87 you get signed off for solo flight
and that has to be renewed every 90 days
you can't take passengers or go above a
broken or overcast layer so as unwise as
it may sound if you're only visually
rated you can take off fly over clouds
with the expectation that when you get
to your airport the weather is forecast
to be clear or at least you're hoping
it'll be clear they won't let you do
that if you're a student pilot the CFI
may also add other limitations like a
maximum
wind for example each each cross-country
flight so if you're going from for
example Hanscom field up to Portland
Maine as a solo cross-country or to
Keene New Hampshire that requires that
you do the flight plan and review it
with the CFI doesn't have to be a
regular CFI and have the CFI sign off
that your planning is adequate you can
actually fly in bravo airspace we'll get
into that a little bit later the most
controlled airspace in the US basically
right around the biggest airports
however you have to have a sign-off from
the flight instructor you can actually
land at a cost Bravo Airport Salt Lake
City has a flight school so they
obviously have people who are soloing a
huge commercial airport however in the
FAR's appendix d some airports are
excluded from student use of the actual
runways as opposed to the airspace Logan
happens to be running one of them okay
so once you get your private pilot
certificate what can you do this is what
I like to do fly over Boston I got the
family in the back we start in the
Cirrus we end up at Provincetown we find
the whales by you know after a careful
study of marine biology I've learned
that the best way to find whales is to
look for a whale watching boat there
just offshore and say it's actually a
lot of time it's about 20 minutes to
p-town and the whale watch cruises that
leave from p-town you know those are
three or four hours so this is a very
efficient way to see the whales okay who
is eligible a lot of people solo on
their 16th birthday and they get a pilot
certificate on their 17th birthday you
can do it even a little bit younger
you're younger and gliders and balloons
you must have that CF I sign off to take
the practical test passed a knowledge
test that's kind of the end of this
course and meet the experience
requirements that means at least you
know 40 hours of total time
three hours of night and so forth ten
hours of solo okay
flight proficiency so this is the stuff
that's in the airman certification
standards that we talked about so it
says you know you got to be able to fly
power power off landing you've got to be
able to you know do a shot demonstrate a
soft field takeoff like how you would
take off if you were on grass and so
forth everything's in there including
some basic instrument training actually
the FAA has three hours of training and
they want you to demonstrate that you
can fly by reference to instruments at
least at least well enough to get back
out of the cloud that you an inverting
Lee flew into so as I noted you need 20
hours of training from a CFI minimum ten
hours so a minimum the other ten hours
is at your discretion almost all people
would choose to do that with an
instructor because it's not a big added
cost compared to the airplane rental the
training from the CFI will include one
long cross-country that's kind of the
interesting part 100 mile nautical mile
cross country I think it has to stop it
three different airports so the one you
took off from and two more like a
triangle flight and those three hours of
instrument training I told you about in
the three hours of test prep within two
calendar months oh yeah so actually
sorry I was I was mistaken about this
100 nautical mile cross-country flight
at night does not require three legs but
you're so low you have to do one so 150
nautical mile trip three legs of you
know about 50 nautical miles each wasn't
one at least 50 nautical so that's the
one that where the FAA things okay this
person is really good to go and start
taking his or her friends which as I
said earlier you know you might think
that that might not be what the friends
want they might say no I'd rather be in
a five seat Cirrus with you and the more
experienced pilot in the front and
we'll sit in the back and party alright
so this is a little bit tricky but
basically you can fly if it's part of
your business so you know if your
company requires you to get to a meeting
you can do that with a private pilot
certificate generally though you have to
be paying for most of the stuff that you
do you can't let your friends you know
pay the full cost of renting the
airplane for example you can tow a
glider there's kind of elaborate rules
that have gotten more complex every year
about how to do charity flights but it
can be done
regulation versus insurance so here's a
question for you what if hypothetically
speaking somebody shut down the
government and there was no FAA could
this could this work and I think
actually it could you would just say
it's illegal to fly without insurance
because let's think about it
the FAA says you can go to East Coast
Aero Club fly around on a piper warrior
get your certificate and then just get a
couple sign offs from an instructor for
complex high performance actually I
guess is three high altitude and then
you know at forty three hours of flight
time you get yourself into this five
million dollar Pilatus pc-12 you've got
the entire family you pitched your tent
at Oshkosh everybody's happy well that's
legal from the FAs point of view but the
insurance company says you know we don't
really want to buy you a new pilates
after you go sideways off the runway at
Oshkosh so we're not going to let you do
that you don't have enough experience
you're gonna need specific training
afford the airplane the FAA again this
is a single-engine land airplane it's
not over 12,500 pounds
so you don't need a type rating and
therefore you could just you know get in
there
most people don't lock the door so just
jump in push the start button and go FAA
is happy well again the insurance
company wouldn't have let you do that to
begin with so if this complex regulatory
environment didn't exist but insurance
were required
I think he'd end up with something that
was
substantially similar and basically the
same the fa assisted I will say in favor
of it it's kind of motivational it's
sort of like the badge system that the
Boy Scouts I guess they're not Boy
Scouts anymore the scouts and the Girl
Scouts they're still the Girl Scouts
that the scouts run and it motivates
people to get the next one
everything except the drones is hanging
off either the pilot or the CFO
certificate and just remember that
you're gonna stay FAA current by flying
every quarter and with an instructor
every two years a lot of people in New
England though they don't fly much
during the winter so they go up and do a
currency flight in the spring time
before the flying season starts so while
you're thinking about your questions
about the regulatory framework are
learning to fly I'll just show you a
fight that you could do with just a
private there is an entangled whale in
New York Harbor with fishing gear all
over him and the people that could
untangle him we're in Provincetown so
Noah asked me to volunteer because they
knew they had my email from the sea
turtle flights they said hey would you
mind flying over Boston picking these
guys up in Provincetown going over New
York Harbor - in the area just outside
of it to look for the whale landing on
the New Jersey Shore so they can get
into a Zodiac boat and chase after the
whales they didn't tell me to go visit
my parents in DC but I did well they
were out chasing the whale and then come
back and I dropped them off I think
right just after sunset I landed at
Provincetown after sunset and then I did
a night flight over water in a
single-engine plane that's about to its
reach it's just reached its 2000 hour
overhaul for the engine so maybe that
wasn't the wisest thing to do but I do
have a life jacket and an end raft so
that was an entire day of flying from
about 7 a.m. to about 9 p.m. when I
landed back in hands come in I think
that didn't require more than a private
certificate go so it's all volunteer
people say like have you ever been
scared Phillip you've flown 4,000 hours
what's the scariest
it's ever happened to you and I think
actually it was on this flight because
if you see there's that IFR that's an
that's an IFR intersection the FAA came
up with so for those of you who are
familiar with Judaism you will know that
it's not something you ever want to see
alright so who has a question about that
material or we should or should we zip
into systems the question is are there
any medical conditions that really
preclude a person from getting a pilot
certificate or getting the medical to go
with a pilot certificate I guess you
need the medical to get it because you
need to so the FAA they have an
exemption proc process and they have
their own physicians in Oklahoma City
that review so usually you can work with
an aviation medical examiner and get
some kind of exception diabetics they're
kind of concerned about but if the
person has a long history of controlling
it well they'll usually give an
exemption people have you know Hart
bypasses and then they have to go
through some rehabilitation process that
makes the FAA happy so it's all laid out
there's a lot of stuff online about the
standards that they use and it's
complicated but the doctors there's a
lot of good local aviation examiner's
one of them works right at Cambridge
Hospital so that's a fairly easy
question to get answered
you